and that previous what's the matter I
thank God I'm sorry there's some things
that I gave her
hey you just leave her
[ __ ] warlords in the country commands
a heavily armed militia using it to
control several important districts
listening which means none of our
humanitarian aid you have to find your
mall and eliminate oh no oh no you
weren't supposed to see this
no that's it it was kinda wet it was
Kanye West I swear to god it was Kanye
wait your dad is Kanye West to go and
breath - Pam welcome back to some more
beyond - solace we're gonna play the
mission which is in the middle of the
story I'm very hungry
and then when I'm hungry I'm grumpy so
grump appears in this episode never done
that before but enjoy I guess we're not
the only grumpy one yeah
never seen anything like it boss sends
his own private helicopter to get an
agent back all the top brass are crazy
about you Jodie you a knight and of
course Joe Oh God so this is just when
we left the place or whatever
listen I know this one was tough but
it's over going home
just another mission accomplished right
or maybe nine oh actually we don't know
what she felt like day
unless she's coming back from the
mission in the last episode cuz then I'm
an idiot she's wearing that necklace
what was that hot jeez it's like I don't
know [ __ ] yes it's definitely after I
thought I didn't could heal it let's
look at the window that's what girls do
right
let's get some massage it's official
recognition of the election of the new
president Jamal Sheikh Sharif Jamal
Sheikh Sharif the most dangerous war
lords in the country after that a
picture of Europe in the background were
assassinated in what appears to be an
unclaimed attack if to find Jamal and
eliminating hopes were high that the
newly recognized President Jamal Sharif
would be able to put an end to the
hostilities that have ravaged his
country for me
that was his mission a number of world
leaders have already expressed outrage
at what appears to be nothing less than
a cold blood what you have to find your
mom
Wow you must have five - son Jamal you
lied to me are you talking about
the person wade into your background
your point we're not politicians we had
our orders
so you like to me oh it's not [ __ ]
choir practice in case you haven't
noticed now we had a job to do and we
did and it stores job to you okay I
don't go around killing people dissing
for [ __ ] starch other he tells me to
what's going on hey hey hey Oh Jodie you
need a cello chill that was not a chill
pill before well damn
I can't control it
[Music]
wait what how was that doors way to ease
it open but damn damn Sam's Lambo rang
that was pretty epic I like that that's
pretty [ __ ] cool so that's how we
ended up in the [ __ ] forest no it's
actually not at all how we ended up in
the pocket for it the story's too
confusing for me I'm just I'm too stupid
Oh Papa pills I mean daddy Dafoe no [ __ ]
that guy no no they're in a way you
can't run away from them she'll hunt you
down and they'll find you you've got to
come in Jody we'll talk I'm sure they're
not gonna make you forced to do anything
more you tell them they try to fight
[Music]
ma'am Hey
oh yes finally okay this is after the
desert yes yes this is what I wanted
this is what we're getting this is what
I'm liking uh-huh we have long hair gaps
a forehead is too big that is the guy
that used to be a date and he's standing
in the park Beckett know what I'm mad
about that is adorable
I think it's gay about this is anything
wrong with
and those it's always yeah
now
sup yeah good to see you too buddy sup I
was worried looking [ __ ] I had no choice
Dawkins let's ask about Dawkins Nathan
oh he's the big boss he's running the
DPA well that's good he's come a long
way since the days about how did the
experiments go any progress on the info
what if something billions into
developing a new condenser the most
powerful ever created of course that was
only possible was he armed yeah
oh my coal and you what are you working
on small group we're trying to classify
types of entities see if they've
different species that kind of thing
it's not the highest priority but I get
to do it over sounds good
what I talked to you about
did you find out anything about why
and the day you were born a woman named
Norman Oh her mother the DP Hospital
a child was declared stillborn but she
wasn't was the dad father did you learn
anything about him his name was Jonathan
Nichols he died before no villian
that's all I could find
where where's Nora now
she was interned in a psychiatric
hospital just after she gave according
to a file she should still be there now
Hospital I'm sorry Judy
I've gotta go see her Jody I know how
you feel but she's in a mental hospital
so why not get the answers you're
looking for
I'm not looking for answers I just need
to see her I mean don't you understand
she's my mother if I can look her in the
eye I could find out who I truly am
she's in a high-security PA facility and
you're wanted by every law enforcement
agency in the country
jeez when did she get so eager all the
sudden how doesn't even make sense
I thought : was her mom call his way
cooler mouth I'd rather have coldest
mamas in mental one
what as I mean wait easy you're gonna
help us see Cole is a cooler mom that's
what I was tired man what is going on
here I cannot tell one bit of what's
going on you'll guard one gate empty
it's a crap
and come here - wait no car girl girl
coal you could loser your JB all right
fine it's raining Kent Kent I didn't use
like an umbrella or something
Oh - I be here forever and I'll always
be your friend coming up that dick about
to Purdue Purdue with the end st. Johns
has a patella
I would suffer a fair fella I try to bid
Ryan
but the path approach yeah all right all
right dick face
where the [ __ ] is NORAD gray right here
oh oh oh okay
lies I knew I forgot something
I'm sorry all visitors must have how is
he doing looking at porn come on come on
what are you doing back day no god damn
it
all right well let's [ __ ] with him
what happens to his [ __ ] eyes all
right authorization give it to me maybe
it's behind a desk probably it's right
there yeah how the hell he do you know
that guesses so people can't just run up
huh I guess that makes sense don't you
don't you think it makes sense I think
it makes sense
it makes sense don't you think it makes
sense I think makes sense don't you
think it'd make sense girl don't you
think they'd make things butter sorry
I'll stop
I don't know what's wrong with me
seriously I'm having one of those days
okay all right now I find a way to open
that door oh well I know what way
clickety clack of the cloaca like nope
not today stupid eyes bun first Oh No
why can't we just take over his body
like the other one
oh I bet he's like what what that's not
good enough to distract him what the
hell is good enough through the phone is
ring no that radio is ringing ladies
don't rain girl there we go
yeah you love that [ __ ] don't you
alright now it's the perfect time what
how is that not the perfect time if I
was em I will just be freaked out Denton
terilyn tantaran tantaran tintin tintin
tintin tintin theravadin Denton Denton
well now you heard us so that's great
thanks
it feels very merge edgy where they're
the colored walls and the textured tape
the textured roses Oh
no that's not it maybe this door needs
to be closed before you open the other
one let's try that nope
you still fiddling with this computer
he's like what if I sniff it over here
no God what about over here
no all right
think think think
[ __ ] well there's a lot of people
whoa security let's get that away damn
and they're more security I understand
Chad flex that's what you get oh well I
supposed to destroy tafflin
well I did so it's I'd be [ __ ] my
[ __ ] pants if I was him especially at
this moment seeing all that orange light
around him
well I better open this door close it
anyway swipe it like I usually do
through the butt cheeks of a girl I
don't know don't judge my hobbies a lot
of people like to judge oh what's that
that's not nice that's not nice at all
in fact that's very oh I forgot the
[ __ ] thing that he left yeah I got it
thanks thanks beautiful picture way to
leave your fingerprint and all that
mm-hmm
[Music]
sure the CIA don't have you in their
database well it's a beautiful place at
least Jesus why remember in Fahrenheit
like the asylum there's one too
it's pretty funny seventh floor room 43
right
crazy people freak me out oh I guess you
need to play more horror games call oh
[ __ ]
Cole watch out the camera yes nailed it
[ __ ] it's cool gonna lose his job now
cuz you're an idiot
oh [ __ ] the cold the camera watch out
gosh Cole Cole doesn't even give [ __ ]
use the one with something at stake here
no he found it it's gonna be okay
she may have lost her mind she might not
even know you're there you shouldn't go
in a way to say now of course she's
gonna go God of course we're gonna go
right Brea's God God whoa that is
[ __ ] creepy nope I'm out of here
sorry sorry not god I have to talk to
her hi what do you say to create people
uh a nice shirt oh god oh god it's over
Juhi run
sit down anyway she looks younger than
us
Wow
and that looks not that fun
if they're poles gonna go up or
something she looks dead
do you think their memories or whatever
I guess we are doing that [ __ ] from her
from her genitals that's highly
inappropriate oh she had the same power
is she saying she got pregnant
[Music]
let us take care of everything it's for
the best
you know let us know as soon as anything
unusual was all part of the pad increase
the dose make sure she never regains
consciousness
no no the drug hands
no Joey don't eat don't say that you
could have not known we got a rescue her
whoa what is this
[Music]
I think we share but how like a yes it's
only I spirit
I was so afraid I would never seen
I've missed you so much Jordan missed
you so much
what did they do to you the drugs they
gave me trapped me in this hell there's
nothing nothing I can do just wait for
it to end I'm gonna get you out of here
yeah I'm gonna help you yeah it's too
late
no it's too late No
I love you more than anything else
nothing will ever change that
oh she stole her necklace
so we're not gonna do anything about it
oh that's a good way to second wait a
second flowers there it's not a clue
well I figured someone visited her and
it's like this third person yeah we
don't know about it but I guess I was
wrong
I love these ambience no we're staying
then it looks like there's something
else we can do
oh we can kill her I can't just leave my
mom to rot in a place like this that's
no way of living that's no way of life
sorry Jodi's mom
[Music]
she looks at me
always be with you
ah all right gonna have to end this
episode here maybe like if you enjoyed
watching
I gotta do something really manly like I
care really big Cooper's right sales up
see you tomorrow breast lobby in drowsy
so I feel like in the skins it's gonna
like take advantage that's the kind of
mind [ __ ] we're talking about here all
right